أريد أن أسأل بينما ننهي
هذا وننهي هذا العام الرهيب
حول عام 2020 عن حقيقة أنه
كان صعبًا للغاية بالنسبة لنا جميعًا ،
فأنت لست استثناءً ، حيث يُنظر إلى
الكثيرين على أنك بطل خارق ولكنك
إنسان وقد كنت كذلك  العمل دون توقف
لأن كل هذا بدأ في التواصل
مع الجمهور في
محاولة للتغلب على هذا الوباء
من حيث العلم ،
فكيف يمكنك الاستمرار في
مواجهة كل هذا الموت والمرض
الذي تعرفه ، دوني دانا ، إنها تركز فقط
على  ضخامة
المشكلة وحقيقة أن لدي دورًا
في الاستجابة لهذه المشكلة
وكلما حدث ذلك ، عليك
التركيز
مثل شعاع الليزر على الهدف من
إنهاء هذا التفشي الرهيب الذي نمر به
وأنا لا أعرف حقًا أنه ليس
لديك وقت
للشعور بالأسف على نفسك لأنك
متعب أو أنك تشعر أنك
يجب أن
تمتص الأمر كما كنت أستخدمه لأن
هذا ما أشعر به في وقت ما
ولكن هذا  ماذا تفعل
لريالى  لأننا هنا
في هذا البلد وفي هذا العالم مع
الكثير من الأشخاص الذين يعانون
ويموتون من هذه الآفة الرهيبة التي
نحن في ظلها ،
لذا دعنا ننتهي من الأمر وعندما
تفعل ذلك ، عليك فقط
التركيز والسعي لتحقيقه  وكل شيء آخر
يصبح ثانويًا
جيدًا وهذه نصيحة جيدة جدًا بالتأكيد يقوم
عمال الرعاية الصحية بذلك في
المستشفيات في جميع أنحاء البلاد
بينما نتحدث ونحن نقدر خدمتك